[Music]
commencement one of the most exciting
days of the year it's not too often you
have a family member or a loved one
graduating from MIT it's like inviting
somebody into your home you want it to
look good when the rhododendrons are
blooming it's beautiful
[Music]
it's really logistically challenging we
last year had 20 856 graduates and we
presented 2,300 pounds of diplomas
students get their diploma their piece
of history from the president of the
provost on stage to make that happen
is an incredible amount of work behind
the scenes our registrar staff is
preparing 2,500 plus diplomas to be in
exactly the right order we're very
careful and precise and it's a team
effort by a group of my staff there is a
great flux students are hoping to make
their diploma some do some don't so
we're continually monitoring advising
students they line up according to their
degree in school in alphabetical order
there's 70 station aides and then
there's a team of marshals that then
lead each of these specific groups out
to Killian court
[Music]
thank you they have to say their last
name and we'll be checking at that point
to make sure the student hasn't dropped
an invert 'only out of line or got lost
or something he is absent was but was
marked here yes my office keeps the
master list of the marching order there
is checks upon checks upon checks
because one student gets out of line
with a domino effect
jameelah s smith down as a graduate
crosses the stage they are handed their
actual diploma whereas many other
schools they're mailed their actual
diploma and their hand in a fake
certificate at the time of graduation we
want the students actually come off the
stage holding their actual degree so it
is a very flexible dynamic walking of
2,800 people to Killian Court
I've always felt that for MIT to do this
for their students says a lot about MIT
you quoi Elliot s Ishmael Rachel and
Hoffman
Athena why Kwang Lakeisha Jane students
will leave me the pronunciation of their
names on my voicemail
Amelie I know who you are
Maximiliano zuluaga Maximiliano
sebastian zuluaga the real trick is
getting where the emphasis is in
someone's name de mis w luck mojo and if
you place emphasis on the wrong syllable
then you can really botch a name Andrew
je-yoon and ER jinhwan lang it's not
just the complexity of an individual's
name but it's going from a Chinese name
to an Indian name to an American name to
a German name it's that switching from
one language to the other that can
sometimes be challenging Camille I henro
nagamma Nyak auntie Amy s Ishiguro
the ones who know they have a difficult
name when you get it right they smile
it's a good feeling
neaten center of Kumar Marie P olymbia
mu do one of the greatest challenges is
the
to set up 14,000 chairs takes hundreds
of people
basically what you're doing is taking
Killian Court and making it into a big
stadium
we set up these great big jumbo Tron's I
see a lot of really happy waving smiling
happy families out there for tens of
thousands of people around the world who
want to be a part of this special day
they can watch this on the webcast we
have about 250 volunteers each year that
handle different functions for our
guests making sure that they get into
the court having a good place that's it
having some information available we are
there to take care of the guests you
know make sure they know where they're
going they all have water they all have
programs they all have a seat we order
bottled water probably nearly 20,000
bottles
[Music]
this is New England the weather can go
to the extremes we have on hand 18,000
ponchos they are available to our
graduates too and we encourage them to
wear under their gowns the people that
come from other jobs because they
volunteer to do it it's really important
to them that all the chairs are straight
that everything looks beautiful and I
think that it gives them a sense of
serving the students and it makes them
feel good about their job
it gives time to pause and sort of think
wow what an amazing place to work and
how lucky I am to be part of such a
great experience congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]